parler de camille combal voilà camille
combal et on se posait une question à
propos de camille combal est il devenu
un people comme les autres parce que mon
oeil sur tf1 grand le chêne première
chaîne d'europe et donc voilà c'est la
question qu'on s'est posée on l'a vu à
la une d'un magazine ya pas très
longtemps avec sa copine très belle
copine d'ailleurs ça marche bien tf1
donc je pose la question franchement ça
veut dire quoi ça restait à venir que
sur tf1 on a on a je sais pas alors vous
sébastien qui paparazzi tout le monde
notamment les gens de d'als est ce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est devenu un people
comme les autres et est-ce qui vous
intéressait en fait il nous intéresse
est moins là je pense que c'est un one
shot on va le voir une fois en planque
mais je pense que wayne aux amis là vont
pas lâcher toutes les semaines
ouais
c'est normal qu'on s'intéresse à lui au
moment du lancement d'alsat du nil est
nouveau dans l'émission il ya vu plutôt
de bonnes critiques
c'est celui qui intéresse le plus après
pamela ou pas dans le dans la leçon ce
moment wallon je pense que pamela a
quand même on a fait tonner sur pamela
pendant un certain temps
j'en pouvais plus là non mais rien parce
qu'elle vous fait ces photos elle les
achète mais l'at elle découvre
d'ailleurs vous pas beaucoup à l'aise
parce que y'a le magazine complètement
faux à gauche et là la fois la vraie
planque et caché ben addi dessus comme
on dit de la merde parce que c'est faux
quoi c'est alors myriam complètement
bidon même ses vidéos karine ferri
effectivement montré ce magazine là qui
dit toujours n'importe quoi ouais non à
gauche et reconnaît toujours nous qui
achetons déjà jour nous on vous met tous
un peu dans le même panier de près cela
qui nous fait du mal parce qu'en fait
ils disent n'importe quoi c'est même pas
y'a même pas de recherche c'est là mais
vous savez pas du couvent pas en parler
car effectivement mais on en parlera
d'elle on parle pas de karine ferri on
parle de camille combal fait avec sa
nouvelle copine
alors est ce que oui ou non voilà ces
vendeurs ou pas oui c'est vendeur
camille combal en fait nous quand on se
dit est ce que amis people et bankable
ou pas on regarde les audiences une
émission on voit si ça buzz sur le net
et si les deux sont réunis ont dit on va
y aller puisque les gens forcément ça
les intéresse d'accord dont très bas
donc il sait à quoi s'en tenir
il ya un petit nom qu'est ce qui se
passe ailleurs mais je ne porte pas de
jugement basse avec grâce et vous ne
sait où il voudra si oui par mais je
disais je porte pas de jugement jeudi
tout sur la qualité des magazines ce qui
est intéressant dans ce qu'on a vu c'est
que dans la même semaine on lui prête 2
2 mais la liaison ça veut dire ça mais
nous comptons et puis quand on quand on
lit la presse on est on est chez le
coiffeur ou quoi quand on lit on sait
pas que tel magazine est moins fiable
que tu es là tu vois là qu'on est déjà
battu à les photos les photos elle parle
pourquoi balas et à la photo à gauche et
camille combal peut-être sur le plateau
et karine ferri c'est normal ils
travaillent ensemble c'est une photo
posée
maintenant si vous avez une photo dans
la rue en train de s'embrasser et de se
tenir la main de sa copine c'est quand
même plus probante donc donc pour vous
quand c'est des photos ou les vois pas
tous les deux ensemble où il n'ya pas
les photos on s'est pris ensemble c'est
mieux dans la presse people ça veut dire
qu'en général ça peut être faux abbas il
ya que des titres accrocheurs avec que
des photos
troquer ou people est un marché
difficile en ce moment il faut souhaiter
que ça fasse vendre qu'il devienne un
people pour donner du grain à moudre à
nos à nos confrères de s'est pas non
c'est pas avec comme il est sympa pour
un cliché comme toi je pas convaincu que
son pack a one shot a fait polémique au
balcon il a une vie trop normal ou faut
que ça trompe tout ça moi non mais vous
l'avez personnage hyper sympathique les
gens l'aiment beaucoup
franchement c'est quelqu'un qui marche
bien en couverture une photo du manque
c'est venu rejoindre myriam palombes am
bien quelqu'un c'est vrai partenaire la
soirée